today's featured presenter is Linda
Smith Linda Smith brings over 30 years
of experience in marketing sales and
general management across a diverse set
of industries and has spent the last 20
years working in the area of high
technology products and services in
their capacity as an SVP marketing chief
marketing officer for a number of
companies including Genesis Jeanette
Genesis telecommunications laboratories
wants Genpact jive Lee video and Tullio
Linda has owned the full end-to-end
marketing responsibility for the
organization she had successfully driven
product marketing product management
corporate marketing failed marketing
demand creation channel marketing
develops developer outreach marketing
research and strategy development she is
currently working as a consultant and
advisor for a variety of startups
ranging from social robotics to
cloud-based development services she has
experience in business-to-business
consumer and developer platform
companies her global background is
extensive with hands-on work with the US
Europe India China and other major
markets
Linda has an undergraduate degree in
liberal liberal arts from Simpson
College and an MBA from universe from
Wharton School of Business at the
University of Pennsylvania she is on the
faculty of Stanford University where she
serves as a lecturer in global
entrepreneurial entrepreneurial
marketing in the engineering school and
diverse programs for the Stanford center
for professional development her passion
is what is happening in this next
generation of marketing or digital media
and social networks are reshaping the
discipline now I would like to turn the
floor over to Laura all right great
well fantastic to be with all of you and
this is a really big topic we're not
going to be able to get through every
possible detail but I really have a goal
today of being able to help you see
where this world of growth hacking is
really going and so we're gonna go
through a number of things I want to
develop an understanding of what growth
hacking is it's big debate about is
growth hacking marketing or not we're
explore how growth hacking is and isn't
life the traditional marketing you may
have experience with and then I want you
to gain some basics that you could start
implementing growth hacking in your
business now I'm gonna tell you growth
hacking has traditionally been really
focused on online businesses its natural
there it's a fit and you'll see that as
we go through but I've had some
experience now even working with a
hardware company where we've been able
to take principles of growth hacking to
really drive revenue and drive the
business so want to give some
perspectives on that as well so we're
gonna be looking at growth hacking how
its defined the basics of growth hacking
well dive into your website because
that's the heart and soul of a growth
hacking strategy and then we'll get into
process testing and tools so the jury's
out isn't marketing or not and it's
really funny because I'll get into
conversations with people who have on
their business card how to growth growth
hacker and get this feeling from them of
no it's not marketing it's something
totally different
well it isn't it isn't we're going to be
talking about that but I gotta tell you
there have been some great brands with
great growth stories that all really
came back down to how they implemented
these basic principles around growth
hacking so it started a while ago and
and people will say well how long has it
been around in business how many years
have people been doing growth hacking
well the reality is it does kind of date
back all the way to 1996 now there was a
company called hotmail that you may or
may not be familiar with but they were
really one of the first people who
implemented some of the core principles
that we now see as a part of everyday
growth hacking and it really came down
to someone having to rethink how to do
marketing based on an absence of money
to spend so they had to get super
creative now the way the hotmail story
goes down is that they were working with
their VC and one of the VCS suggested
well hey why don't you use the product
itself to be able to get other people to
jump on and so they created a backlink
so essentially every time you got an
email from someone with a hotmail
account it enables you to click on that
link go back and sign up for an account
yourself so some might say that
this world of growth hacking really
started off back with hotmail in 1996
probably in modern terms though we
really related back to around the 2010
timeframe that's when the term was
really coined and it was coined by a
gentleman by the name of Sean Ellis and
the reason he coined the term was he had
had some great startups experienced some
great exits and everyone saw what this
guy was doing in terms of marketing that
felt different and so they would hired
him to really help him get them started
on it come in and get them off the
ground well he didn't want to be there
full-time it was time for him to move on
to the next venture and so he needed to
hire someone to step into his shoes and
he put out there a basic resume that
said hey looking for a VP of Marketing
looking for a chief marketing officer
and he wasn't finding the right skills
coming through when he would do the
interviews so he decided alright I'm
tired of doing this I'm gonna come up
with a new term that's better describes
this individual that better describes
what I need henceforth the term growth
hacker was invented and he went out with
that resume and ended up getting the
right type of people or the right type
of job description and getting the right
type of people on top of that so what is
growth hacking well it lives in this
very interesting intersection between
the traditional discipline of marketing
that we all know and product development
and when you look at the basic Wikipedia
term which i think is a very strong
representation of this world of growth
hacking basically says it's a process
it's data-driven and it has a lot of
rapid experimentation in it and when you
think about the difference from the
traditional world of marketing the
traditional world of marketing seems
much more planned especially when you
get into large campaigns the months the
weeks that go into planning it it's not
about that rapid experimentation
necessarily so I think when you really
look into growth hacking it's this
discipline that lives at a very
interesting intersection it heavily
involves products but it's data-driven
and it also has this construct of rapid
iteration and we're going to drive a
little more into that as we proceed here
so when you think about the mission of a
tacker it is about creating this
self-perpetuating machine and this is
largely tied to this idea of using the
product itself to grow the target
audience and we'll talk about how that's
done Aran's from ever laying stumble
upon again one of the leaders in this
idea of growth hacking as a discipline
saw great success from it but he really
is the one who came back with this idea
it's about self perpetuation it's about
getting the product itself to do the
marketing for you having that into this
having used the principles myself this
is how I look at it in terms of court
tenants so to start off it does have
this deep tie-in product and we'll be
talking about in terms of implementation
how people leverage the product to do
this it's dependent on for allottee
gonna go deeper into that as well
it lives in analytics so this is back to
that data-driven principle it involves
staying with the customer across the
entire funnel process now I will say the
trend in marketing is for markers to
actually be more involved across the
full customer lifecycle but here in
growth hacking the growth after the
leader the head of it feels like I own
every aspect because I've got to make
sure that that product is doing what it
needs to do to actually drive back room
it's a company culture and it's a
mindset again gonna give you some more
details on each of these so let's start
off with the product yes product is
always been a part of the marketing
discipline and where I have been chief
marketing officer I've often had not
only product marketing but also product
management as a part of my team but here
growth hackers they have to have the
products they see themselves as the
people the person who owns the product
and they see that product as that cheap
channel for growth and they also see
optimizing the product as part of their
job so they really take seriously that
they own that product and when I talk
about company culture you'll see how
there's a really interesting difference
there and a lot of the companies that
apply growth hacking but product is
central to what they're trying to do
morality a little more on that getting
your product out there and
such a way that it spontaneously will
drive growth really becomes a big spoken
the virality stems from its being
engineered into the product itself so
this goes back to ideas like the
backlink and we'll go through a whole
list of these in products tools that are
actually used so a growth hacker is
looking every day and how do I make this
go viral and when you think about it
just a few quick rules on morality first
of all rule number one is make it easy
for others to spread your products
baffling hotmail we talked a little bit
about that it's also about provoking the
desire to spread the product to have the
product just be something that everyone
wants to share out and then world number
three is finding ways to do all of this
without spending very much money so
morality is very key to all of this and
again the reason why the growth hacker
feels they own the product if that
product has to be pretty darn special to
create that notion of morality analytics
so the first day that a growth hacker
gets on the job may be different than
any other position that you see he dives
in he or she dives in and really looked
at what are the event based analytics
that I need to understand what's going
on with the product how are people using
it how signup going how are people going
through a signup flow and then they'll
sit down with anyone that touches
someone where they need analytics and
really look for how are we going to wire
this product are we going to wire the
website like get the analytics I need to
drive growth into the company part of
the reason and analytics again very
important across all forms of marketing
but for the growth hacker one it keeps
them honest because he really is going
through anything yeah let's let's look
at where our success track record is
what works what didn't work let's keep
what works let's not dive any further
into stuff that's not working it allows
the growth hacker to stack rank the two
dudes because every day is about
experimentation every day the growth
hacker is waking up looking at the
numbers and saying what we're gonna try
today to initiate more growth
it makes success repeatable since again
you know what's work and not work and
also allows you to somewhat predict the
future
so analytics another one of the key
thrusts in growth hacking the funnel
process again in all marketing
disciplines we have a funnel we're
trying to drive people through that
funnel here the growth hacker thinks
about owning all the steps acquisition
activation retention revenue and then
that referral that referral that drives
that for ality so keen interest in
owning everything that touches the
funnel company culture now this is the
pizza when I get into these discussions
with friends who say yep I'm the head of
growth I'm a growth hacker the thing
that I found is different about their
companies from other companies is they
are empowered from the top down to own
anything that might get in the way of
growth so if you think about
traditionally marketing in an
organization is appear to other
disciplines the engineering discipline
the customer support discipline the IT
discipline GA all the disciplines in the
company and that head that CMO that had
a marketing is sitting at a table with
their peers reporting in to the CEO what
I found in the culture of companies that
are truly embracing this idea of growth
hacking is the CEO has essentially told
those peers hey you work for me but you
also work for a head of growth at any
point in time if our head of growth says
you need to change something do
something differently you've got to get
out of the way and make it happen
because that's the person who owns the
numbers that's the person that we've got
to enable so there's a different level
of power if you will for that head of
growth then you might find the head of
marketing having in other company and
then as I said it's a mindset you know
it really comes down to when you talk to
people who are passionate about being a
growth hacker what they think about is
hey my job isn't marketing as you might
know it my job is driving growth my job
is owning the revenue number or the user
number and it's about doing it really
fast because growths
have to move quickly so there's a
different mindset that you might find in
someone that considers themselves truly
a growth hacker if you're hiring for
this head of growth there are a few
things that you really
need to be looking for this person has
to be passionate about data they have to
love waking up every morning and living
in the numbers and understanding how
those numbers are shifting and changing
over time
they're super curious about everything
they're poking at everything they're
poking at the products of poking at
customer support so poking on anything
that might change where those numbers
are going they're infinitely creative
they want to try all sorts of stuff
throw it up against the wall see what
sticks they're obsessive they when it
comes to they've tried something and
yeah kind of work well let's try it
again see if we can do it better they're
constantly trying to be that
experimenter out there and they live in
the user experience because the only way
you're gonna get people to be raising
fans to spread that word of mouth to
drive that for allottee is if they're
not only people who like what you've
offered but they paramount of enough of
it they care enough about of it about it
to actually be passionate and help you
drive that growth so what is different
I'll leave that up to you to decide if
you think it's a completely different
discipline or not but I thought this
says this Dilbert was pretty funny
what's your marketing strategy marketing
is dead I'm a growth hacker we create a
product and market fit we fight scrappy
ways to get the word out and we optimize
with data to grow well part of that is
that marketing it's all of my hubris so
gives you a little bit of an idea of the
growth hacking how its defined how it
may be a little bit different from what
traditional marketing will look like but
let's get into what's probably really
important to you the basics of growth
hacking so I talked about the fact that
growth hackers feel like they own the
whole funnel you saw a five-step funnel
that I had in the front section of our
discussion today here's a simplified
version for the purposes of getting down
to the basics what do you think about a
growth hacking funnel because so much of
it is oriented to the website it starts
off with getting visitors into that
funnel of visitors to that website then
it's about activating members and what
activate really talks about is it's
taking an action that is an indication
of relationship now that may be buying
something it may be signing up for
something it may be something as simple
as stepping into some type of a trial
but it's getting that action that says
alright I'm interested in going further
with you and then it's about retention
and retention is about getting people to
use that product regularly or use that
service regularly so you're looking at
visitors activation and retention and
we're going to dig it and deep into each
of those and some of the basic
principles of growth hacker uses now
conversion rate relative to that funnel
is something that a growth hacker is
constantly looking at and that
conversion rate really is again that
idea of when you move through each
section of that funnel what's going on
in terms of my conversion rates from
getting people there to activating them
to actually retaining them and the other
thing that a growth hacker is constantly
thinking about it boy if I change
something at one stage in this funnel it
may have repercussions elsewhere so for
example maybe I've amplified the number
of users to the top but they're not the
right users so my conversion rate in
activation may greatly change or perhaps
now I've got people activating but the
way that I did it made it everyone asked
abates but I'm not retaining anyone so
growth hackers looking at those
conversion rates also as indications of
are my programs working to move people
through that funnel now question that we
often talk about is what is the truth
about conversion rate you know what is a
good conversion rate what should my
conversion rate be well the reality is
you need to know what they are for your
own funnel and then you have to decide
where you want to move those but if
you're trying to get some idea for
others maybe in a like industry or have
a like target customer you can find some
numbers out there to start you off and
some of those are the factors they're
just published people will publish the
type of conversion rates that they're
seeing you can also enter into the idea
of a buddy system as long as there's not
competition you'll find that a lot of
growth hackers are really happy to share
what numbers they're getting across that
funnel so when you're thinking about
conversion rates you want to start with
a baseline that can be your own baseline
or you can find some
out there that might have that data so
let's talk about how we actually get
people moving let's talk about getting
visitors there are essentially three
ways that visitors will get into your
funnel one is the pull methodology so
they find you some people call that
inbound marketing so it's enabling
people to find where you live there's
pushing so really going to where they
are some people would equate that to
what we normally call outbound marketing
and then what's a little bit different
again coming back to the idea of growth
hacking is how do I use the product
itself to bring people to that top of
the funnel so pull tactics you'll find
that a lot of these are content oriented
so it's things like the blog's gets logs
podcasts videos ebooks visual assets
like infographics it's that realm of
content marketing that has become so
popular it's search engine optimization
super key it's such a great tool because
you can do it with a relatively low
level of spend and we all know that
organic search is better than paid
search in terms of the types of people
that actually come and activate its
social media which you're all familiar
with
and finally it's this idea of leveraging
other people's audiences let me give you
a great example of that when Airbnb
first started out of their marketing
efforts they were looking at well how do
we get people to jump on board and
starts you know really working with us
from our Airbnb perspective being our
customers because it's really hard to
find the customers when you're starting
off and what they did was they leveraged
Craigslist so whenever you would in the
very beginning days you would say yes I
want to put my house up on or my
apartment on my room up on Airbnb they
would say what do you want is also
listed for you on Craigslist and people
would opt in or opt out well most people
opted in and the great news was so now
you had people that had signed up to be
a part of Airbnb but you are actually
using Craigslist the network of people
that have ver ties that you had this
unit available so they were leveraging
someone else's network so a little bit
different tactic that you see in the
growth hacking environment is this idea
of leveraging other people's networks
but for the most part getting people the
top one
through poll looks a whole lot like
traditional inbound marketing talk about
the push tactics again will look a lot
like what you see in traditional
outbound marketing its public relations
its purchase as AdWords display ads
social ads retargeting I'm going to come
back to promo swaps it's email marketing
its webinars its contents it's the stuff
you would traditionally do in an
outbound marketing environment promo
flops is an interesting one because
again get this real friendship going in
the growth sector world and it's this
idea of hey why don't we swap tweets
I'll pay for you you tweet for me let's
swap Facebook post
I'll post for you you post for me we
could even do something like a dedicated
email swap but it's this idea of working
with other companies to jointly promote
yep you've seen that in marketing for
years but you really see it vibrant in
the growth hacking world and again come
back to creativity remember one of the
core principles here was the fact that
we're looking for ways to market that
doesn't take a lot of money that's
highly creative that we can experiment
rapidly on and see what works all right
let's do this is the one that I think is
inherently different in the growth
hacking world from what you have
traditionally seen in other world and
it's this idea of end product tactics
it's using the product itself wiring the
product itself to actually build up that
network to build up that customer base
to build up that morality so let's look
at what those are one of the tactics is
network invitation how many times have
you been in touch for the company and
what they've come back to you and said
is hey can we borrow your phone contacts
could we use your email contacts could
we use your social contacts to bite
other people to come in and use this
service or this product in fact probably
most of you have touched LinkedIn it's
somewhere in your career the way they
got started was by using your email list
they would ask you do you mind if we
send out an offer to everyone that's in
your email address book and invite them
in to be a part of LinkedIn so this idea
network invitations is a big one for
being able to get people on to the
product social sharing
that's probably familiar with everyone
it's making it very easy to be able to
have people get the word out through
their social networks API integrations
okay this really gets to the heart of
tying products together it's integrating
your product with an existing network
again as individuals you've probably
experienced this for instance if Spotify
is something that you've used they've
actually used the Facebook Connect
integration so that you can sign up
using Facebook so by using other
people's API you can leverage that
Network now the pros cons on that you
know the pro is well I guess the full
new network I can leverage the con is
sometimes you'll tie your boat to
someone else and they decide okay we're
tired of having people tie their boat to
us and they'll shut down that ability to
have that integration but again very
product centric way to do things
backlinks we talked about this and the
hotmail example dating all the way back
to the 1990s by providing a link in your
product that easily brings people back
to the top of the funnel back to the
website is a way to grow that audience
incentive Dropbox has been great about
this this idea hey if you get someone to
sign up we'll give you additional
storage free of charge so building
incentives into the product that helps
people grow that morality and then
organic that's the best of all world
your product is so awesome that people
want to share it out so talk about this
idea of morality quite a bit so
something else you need to have in your
data store here is this idea of the
viral coefficient or what we also call
the K value this is where the magic
happens what this basically says it I
want to get every one of my users of my
customers of my people that have signed
up to be a part of this network I want
to get them to invite at least one
additional person if they invite more
than one person well that's awesome
because now you've got four ality and
it's growing and what you're looking for
is the K value that is over
now that's now these need to deal with
all products or services basically there
you're betting that every one of the
people out there is going to invite at
least one additional person but even
getting something northward of 50 0.50
is awesome
so look at for ality look at what you
can get for your K values so we've
talked about how do we get customers how
to get them to that top of the funnel
let's talk about activation an
activation essentially falls into two
buckets two categories there are in
product motivation and then external
motivation the in product motivations
include things like calls to action
getting people that once they've signed
up to actually take that next step to a
great CTA will talk about CTAs as we
talked about your website onboarding
giving a digital tour twitter has done a
great job of this people yeah onion
familiar with the world of micro
messaging getting them in giving them a
guided tour of what's going on in the
product guided experiences this is idea
of oK you've done ask now let's hand
hold and get you to do why so it's
taking people through each step of
onboarding onto that product
gamification who doesn't like earning a
little status who doesn't like getting
that badge that gold star not to mention
the profits report how many times have
you gotten to kind of 80% of building a
profile and they gave up iuj wanting to
get 85 getting 90% incentives and
pricing strategies getting to earn
credits getting to earn special options
because you've done something and then
the idea of leaderboards where they're
right out there in the open and say hey
this is how you compare with the other
people that are onboarding and signing
up so really getting creative in how to
get people beyond just showing interest
but actually activating showing some
level of interest and going further and
then of the external side this ties back
to a lot of what we've done in the
traditional world of marketing drift
campaigns so someone has signed up and
now they haven't gone to the next step
you remind them through other channels
like email so activating very key second
stage
in that very simplified funnel and then
the last stage comes down to the idea of
retention the only way this works is if
you've got people that are so happy with
the product that their word-of-mouth for
you they're inviting other people in
they're making it go viral well that
only happens if you've retained them so
again we have two categories of
retention that you typically see there's
planned and there's organic so plan is
where you're taking really control if
you will first one is speed to value at
Twilio one of the things that we looked
at is once we had a developer that is
signed up for an account getting them
onto the API we wanted to make sure that
they had that instant gratification of
oh wow this is awesome so Twilio was a
platform that allowed developers or
allows developers to bring in messaging
and voice into their application so one
of the campaigns we had was a hello
world campaign that gave them speed to
sending the first text message and it
was amazing people were so excited that
they actually sent a text message with
their app customer communications all
right this ties back into things we do
in the traditional world of marketing
keeping customers and forms feeling a
part of the company feeling a part of
where things are going using things like
newsletters to keep people excited about
being connected into your products in
your company top customer programs
rewards a t-shirt whatever your customer
base wants having them be able to be a
part of it rewarding them with a
customer program building a community
sometimes it's as simple as people being
able to leverage and connect and contact
other people that are using your product
or your service and giving them a
community platform to do that and then
making them fans again one of my one of
main memories of Twilio is you know
walking down the street people seeing at
Twilio too much t-shirt or my Twilio
track jacket and say oh my god we love
Twilio well boy when you have raving
fans they're out there creating that
morality by word of mouth for you on the
organic side again some of that's going
to be very familiar to traditional
marketing the organic things that retain
customers are things like process
switching if you've got a lot invested
in getting started getting set up that's
a high cost of switching and likelihood
is you're going to stay
comfortable with these your experience
wow it's so easy to use I just really
can't think about using something else
and then the network of that even if
maybe the product is not as great as
what someone would want the fact that
everyone else is tied into it will help
people retain so those are your basics
in terms of getting people to the top of
the funnel activating them and retaining
them and believe me we could actually go
into all of those in much more detail
but that gives you the basics so let's
talk about your website the reality is
the website is for a world hacker the
front door it is how people find them
they activate and even retain in the
long run so when you think about the
webpage what you want to think about is
the top of the funnel it's really that
persuades event it's the homepage its
product and services page it's basic
information pages it's all that content
that sets up the value proposition and
persuades people to take an action and
then you think about the transactional
end those pages on your website where
the transaction actually occurs where
that activation actually occurs those
can be formed
those can be shopping carts so as you're
looking at your website a new
perspective it's not just this very
informational source it's not just those
pretty source it's really about this
persuasive end my top of the funnel and
that transactional end that's getting
people to activate now going back to a
difference from a growth hackers
perspective they're thinking about how
do i engineer these pages to drive more
activation to drive more signups it's
not about that nice-looking is it's not
about it's a great content just for
content sake they're really engineering
what's going on so a few best practices
to optimize your site to get those
activations you're looking for first of
all no distractions you know you don't
want people coming to the website oh
that's nice let me wander over here let
me look over here you want to get them
to what you want them to do give them
enough information that they immediately
go I got a sign up speed matters when it
comes to your website if it takes a long
time for things to load and we
all get enamored by Flash and design if
it takes a long time allows you to lose
people we have very short-term memories
you have needs for immediate
satisfaction so speed matters people
value social proof get right out there
on front who else is doing it who else
likes them is interested in the service
or in the product think about every page
is a home page Wow with all the things
that link now to our website someone may
not hit that home page they may actually
come to another page so make sure that
that's fine up that activation
call-to-action is there on every page
and then sync mobile we are a mobile
generation we're a mobile world thinks
mobile first because you may actually
see your activations happening from a
mobile channel talked about a moment ago
this IDF CTA calls to action great calls
to action give clear direction don't
make visitors figure out what you want
them to do don't get overly cute don't
get overly creative make sure that it's
clear that you want them to click here
and sign up make the CTA obvious the
buttons need to stand out and you'll
laugh about you we spent a lot of time
is it a blue button it's a right red
button is a great button the reason we
spend time doing the a/b testing on that
is based on your target audience that
could all be different but make sure
your button stands out for your target
audience and if you have a phone number
involved make it prominent don't make
people go digging for it so a few basics
to how to make your growth hacking
website really stand out now final bit
testing told you that the growth hacker
is constantly looking at the numbers the
course hacker is constant with you
looking at what's working what's not
working so what they're doing is a lot
of a be testing so for those of you who
have not been thrown into the world of
baby testing and thank goodness we have
some awesome software now that helps us
do that the idea is you get visitors to
come into your website put through
automation what you've been able to do
is tee up a number of tests so you can
have a person come in and what they see
on your website is the control page the
standard page that you've had up there
but someone else coming in get served up
variation a while another one gets up
served up variation B and you
can look at what's working are they
hitting the buttons I want them to hit
are they activating are they doing what
I want them to do and with that
information you're able to go back and
revamp what you've got what do you want
to ad test everything it can be the
product itself that your a/b testing but
if your call to action it's the
consonants copy it's the visual it's the
navigation it's those forms that are the
bottom of the funnel its ads it's emails
its pricing again if you're a growth
hacker everyday you're living to try
something new see what works people what
works that throw away what doesn't and
as I said we today have some great tools
that we can use to be able to do this
constant a be testing and you'll find
there are a number of them out there
Optimizely is one that I personally use
but but basically each of these tools
does a great job of splitting that
traffic
it sets the control mechanisms to ensure
each visitor has a consistent experience
rather than a random one tracks the
goals or the conversion rates for each
variation get to some great test shows
these statistical data so that every day
you can try something new and then a
final comment on tools analytics think
all of us as more of marketers have you
know gotten very familiar with general
general analytics things that Google
actually provides to us in addition to
that every growth hacker is going to
dive into event space and people based
analytic tools because they have to
understand what's going on through that
website based on events based on
people's actions not to mention also
inside that product all right so 45
minutes I know we want to leave time for
Q&A
that has given you really kind of the
basic world if you will of what growth
hacking is how you implement a growth
hacking strategy how that is like and
dislike what's going on in marketing and
then looking at process and tools all
right let's jump into some questions so
the first question Linda that we got
submitted is where does growth hacking
be used for services
opposed to products and what is the most
significant difference in applying
growth hacking to services yeah that's a
great question I think let me start off
by answering it in terms of the online
world versus the more traditional world
so when you think about growth hacking
everything I just walked you through
thinking about the website it really
hasn't spent two products and services
that are actually online what I have
found is that there's some elements of
this that we can really draw it in to
services and products that are offered
in an offline world it's things like you
know really thinking about that whole
lifecycle of the customer and how
marketing can be really engaged in it
it's about looking at analytics but
looking at them on a more daily basis so
that it's not just a once a month type
of report it's looking at things like
you know diving deep into my product is
my product what my market needs and
these are all very traditional things we
look at marketing as marketing but when
you're thinking about it in this growth
hacking mentality there's this this
rapid-fire experimentation that comes
into us now in terms of services we you
know when you think about products and
services when you think about services I
think of something like Dropbox actually
as a service it's a storage service
there's a product that's a part of that
but the reality is it's to me as a
consumer it's a service it's my storage
service I think it's really diving into
what your type of service is and in fact
can you think about your service a
little bit differently I hope that
answer that I think that's good so the
next question we have here is can you
give some examples and recent companies
it successfully huge growth hacking and
how they did it
yeah well there's a lot of them are ones
that you're very very familiar with it
really comes down to it any of the
social platforms that we have
participated in you will find that they
are using growth hacking as a large part
of how they look at marketing and
they're using a lot of the inner product
tactics but they're also constantly
everyday driving in to looking at the
product is it offering the features that
my online customer wants you know
LinkedIn
long time ago really get started this
way they continue to operate that way
think about the gamification you have
and I use LinkedIn to those
professionals most of us are familiar
with that social platform you know think
about the gamification that goes on
constantly with them telling us how we
can improve our profiles how much
further we can go along you've seen a
lot of the companies that appeal out to
developers like the Twilio of the world
are using a level of growth hacking in
what they're doing to drive those
conversions you'll actually when you
look back one of the original slides
that I had shared you know Dropbox
Zynga's group on Instagram Pinterest
Twitter Facebook Evernote app sumo
stumble upon ever lane all of these
companies have been very active in using
the growth hacking construct so another
question we have here is what in your
opinion is the best practice for a
startup to build a culture of growth
hacking its best bets of awesome
question first get to your CEO really
fast or if you're the founder get your
head around it
it really does start top-down and so it
I think really comes down to sitting
down with the founders sitting down with
the CEO and really thinking about you
when we look at our approach to how
we're going to drive growth know do we
see this as something that we want
marketing driven and if so that really
started way out and I have listed the
kind of core tenants getting everyone's
heads around that you know how are we
going to use the product for this you
know how is the head of growth involved
and able to really drive and touch all
the disciplines to make this happen so
you think of the way I would approach it
if I were coming into a company I would
say you sit down with the the top
management say is this right for us I
understand and listen to the reasons why
it may or it may not
and then really you know working with
the management you need to say this is
what's going to take for us to really
execute on this so it's got to be top
down the hard part would be if you went
in bottoms up then I've just been hired
as the new CMO know they had a marketing
of this startup and I'm gonna go to
growth hacking and no one from the top
is acknowledging that the
is how we're gonna drive growth and
company and then you just constantly be
hitting brick walls okay so we have
another question here that says
traditionally marketing takes a long
view on bad news or bad mentions in
popular media because eventually it'll
be forgotten and name recognition
benefits eventually outweigh the
short-term losses does this concept hold
true and growth hacking as well I would
say not and I would also from my own
protective and I've worked both in the
startup world as well as very large
companies I'm really familiar with what
you're putting forward there I would say
because of the advent of social media
that the reality of all companies growth
hacking companies and traditional
marketing companies are acting much more
quickly across bad news because they
just can't let it fester out there that
they may have different strategies about
how they're going to do it but it's very
hard to let things just fester cuz they
just don't go away the way they used to
I can tap into my own career without
giving specifics and say there are so
many times that I have seen where maybe
there was one bad review one bad comment
when did you not every time you do a
Google search it comes back up on page
one it's just I wish I could bury it but
I can't get it off the radar so I think
all companies now quite frankly are
having to take a more proactive a more
rapid-fire approach to how they handle
the bad news that's out there now
putting that aside knowing that there's
some very large traditional
organizations that are a little slower
to move on that in a growth hacking
world down you got to constantly be
reacting responding you don't just wait
for something to go away I think also in
the companies that I've watched and
companies have been in that are applying
growth hacking there's much more
transparency in terms of interacting
with that target audience and I think
also there's a new bar that as we look
at Millennials and younger generation
Xers and Baby Boomers there's a
different bar that's also being given to
us by our target audience that says hey
be transparent be rapid make sure you're
connecting with me on good and the bad
or I'm going somewhere else so I think
there's a major shift that's going on
now in the world of marketing and
definitely in growth hacking
yeah address things fast
you move and you get on to the next
thing love that question
a good question yes we have a few people
actually asking something relating to
how the role of a product and marketing
teams are now changed with a growth
hacker and how they are also not you
know how are they thinking about growth
together and how they play a game part
yeah so this comes back to that company
culture model I was talking about in a
more traditional environment what I
would say is if there was a product
issue if you had noticed as the head of
marketing and you didn't own product
management so if he knows that there's a
product issue that is preventing you
from moving forward getting more users
having you know customers who are
negative you would really have to sit
down with your peer and have this
discussion around hey you know I see
these problems I'd like to share them
with you
let's work together to find a solution
and depending on the roadmap depending
on the process that was being used some
product development it may or may not
happen in a period of time in the growth
hacking model the pure true true dat
growth hacking model I wouldn't have to
have that side-by-side conversation
instead I would be empowered to go to
engineering or go to the product
management team and say alright you know
we've lost 15 it was lost 15 percent on
our conversion rates because of X what
are you going to have it changed
so there's a different mentality there
from a cultural perspective and what you
own if you're in real growth hacking now
companies will do hybrid models you know
it's essentially one of the companies
that I'm working with right now we have
that hybrid model the way we've all been
a bear to make sure that we get what we
need to change in the product as it
really comes down to everyone
understands that growth is the number
one objective and everyone into it
saying all right we're all going to look
at the numbers every day you're
responsible for them and driving them as
the head of growth but you know we're
all going to be you know looking at
those numbers each day and you find that
when you create this culture of hey it's
about growth that's our number one
objective even if you don't own it you
can't go and say and
do it because everyone gets so that's
the fundamental goal you'll find a lot
more willingness to be a part of it and
then it's on your shoulders to produce
the reports put up the bright shiny
panels have monitors that are constantly
showing the numbers to get the culture
thinking about a growth culture great so
I think we have time for one more
question so we have another a lot of
people asking you you talk a lot about
some of the tools and strategy strategy
for growth hacker but in your opinion
which are the most effective if any
which are the ones that we need to focus
on in order to be a great car Packer
yeah good question
so first of all it's a you know it
always comes back to who your target
audience is and whenever I look at doing
anything at marketing I always come back
and call it the who I always come back
to trying to figure out who's my target
audience and I ask questions like you
know how do they learn where do they
live what is their temperament towards
you know marketing and I try to really
get in their shoes because Eddie's
tactic you deployed it may be a great
tactic but if it isn't in line with how
your target audience thinks about the
world it's not going to go very far so I
would first say think about who your
target audience is really do that sub
segment ation
really get into their shoes really
understand that that individual you're
trying to cater to and out of that will
follow the tactics now over growth
hacking perspective you know what I
would say is it is begin product if you
have that opportunity because you have
an online product and you are using your
website is the main way that you're
driving growth it's going to be really
looking for what can you do in products
that will spawn other people's interest
so goes back to really that full list of
any product tactics and again it's very
specialized to what your product or your
services but again think about your
consumer think about your customer and
it's by the way this can be done in the
b2b world or the BBC world you know get
in their shoes and that will drive which
of those tactics are going to be most
useful Thank You Linda wait and also
thank all of you for attending this
webinar I hope you
learn something new about growth hacking
and we look forward to seeing you next
time in the next webinar and if you
wanted more information please contact
us and or look at our website at create
stanford.edu
thank you everyone